malgré un nombre plus important de
ménages composés de couple la famille
martiniquaise restent très marqués par
la monoparentalité ici 40 % des familles
sont monoparentales dont 90% sont
composées de femmes une structure
familiale particulière entretenu par la
culture de la femme potomitan mais
derrière le mythe se cache parfois une
grande précarité financière et affective
d'un autre côté l'image du père oscille
entre deux extrêmes
tantôt le prétendu superbe a pas rares
mais efficace dans l'éducation des
enfants tantôt la figure absente du
foyer alors entre réalité et
représentation à quoi ressemble vraiment
les familles martiniquaises en 2019
[Musique]